[Music]
inside of you is brought to you by my
good friends at sonos uh you've heard me
talk about this boy is this the best
holiday gift to holiday treat if you
don't have sonos i have had sonos in my
house for 18 years before these guys
even became a sponsor and uh it's pretty
amazing because instead of having giant
speakers and amps and all these uh you
know uh receivers everywhere you just
had this small device that just sits in
the back that has great sound
sonos you could play a song in each room
a different song in each room you'd have
a party mode for outside you could
listen to
you know mazzy star up in the bedroom
you could listen to the beatles in the
basement it's really wonderful i love
sonos i'm so glad they're a sponsor i
hope they stick around and they'll stick
around if you guys purchase [ __ ] so
that's kind of the way uh look share the
joy of listening on sonos this season
make the sound system on your wish list
a reality with speakers and sound bars
that are easy to set up easy to use i do
it guys
and they all work together so you can
listen in any or any room or every room
like i talked about and bring the family
together with incredible sound for
everything for from classic carols to
festive films sonos works with all your
streaming services and control is simple
with the sonos app your voice using
amazon alexa or google assistant and
apple airplay 2.
spoil the listeners in your life with a
gift that keeps on giving boy boy does
it
treat gamers and movie lovers to an
immersive home theater experience with
beam keep your fitness loving friends
motivated with great sound for their
workout playlists with move and help
relatives relax with hands-free control
of their music and more on sonos one i
love these guys i hope you'll check them
out it's easy you go to sonos
s-o-n-o-s-com
to learn more and wrap up your holiday
shopping that's sonos.com
to learn more
sonos you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum happy holidays
folks happy holidays ryan happy holidays
to you happy holidays happy holidays to
everyone happy holidays i hope
everyone's having a great week great day
great holiday if you're having a bad day
have a better day uh turn it around man
turn it around somehow go for a run go
for a drive go for a listen to some
holiday music if that's what you're into
yeah i like some holiday music oh yeah
what's your favorite holiday song
favorite holiday song
um i just like the simple
have yourself a marrying little
christmas mind's name just being a kid
that's a nice one that one's really that
one tugs at the horses
i mean you can't go wrong with the
mariah carey maybe a wham
wham yeah or maybe even so this is
christmas and what have you done one of
my my dad's favorites to play was the
the chicago oh yeah yeah
yeah because it was chicago 25 so they
made a christmas album so we had that
concert and they have a bunch of bells
and things on the front of the album
yeah probably i think so
uh guys thank you so much for supporting
this podcast all year long uh it means
the world to me if you're here for tom
welling
uh you came to the right show but uh i
hope that you like it enough to listen
to next week
which uh another great um actor and you
know the support means the world it's a
little podcast that can that could
and uh so
follow us
and um those handles on instagram and
facebook are uh
inside of you podcast instagram facebook
on twitter at inside of you pod that's
exactly right it's right here and you
know you can watch the shows on youtube
subscribe you could listen on apple
stitcher tune in spotify make sure you
listen write a review it helps the show
immensely if you're getting something
from these podcasts and uh learning a
little something and you know we have so
many letters that i you know i get that
people just to really um
you know the show helps them and uh in
some way and that means the world to me
uh i'm glad ryan here is still with
better help he's still seeing therapy uh
we're all seeing therapy it's uh it's
gonna be a great next year if this year
was tough for you
there's always tomorrow man i keep
saying hey next year's gonna be better
you just you have to think like that you
have to have that mentality you can't be
like oh it's just gonna get worse you
can't you gotta turn it around man turn
it around
um
also stop by the inside of your store
inside of you online store um 10 off
just put rosie christmas 10
ros ey christmas 10. uh we've got small
the lunch boxes i autograph we've got
some new tumblers we've got some small
shirts we've got pictures autographs
just mugs i think we've got a lot of
great stuff and more stuff on the way so
go to the inside of your online store
and of course sunspin.com if you want to
book a
conversation with me on zoom and uh or
buy some cool merch there so why don't
we just do it let's uh happy holidays
everybody this is my good buddy uh he's
been on before he's been on i think the
most him and stephen amell and zach levi
are probably the leader on the
leaderboard of who's been on the podcast
um but we had a great conversation and i
think you're gonna really enjoy it so uh
let me know what you think
and uh let's get inside of tom welling
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
what's the shirt why is that lady gaga
no dude that's ariana grande let's go
ariana grande why is she upside down in
your shirt i don't know my wife went to
the concert with her friend and brought
me this home and i love it
well it looks good on you and in fact
today i was trying to figure out what to
wear here
and my wife was like what are you gonna
wear and i was like i was like i have
two options i'm doing this i'm doing
this and she was and she's paused
and i was like
okay
so i went back in the room literally and
i'm going through the stack of the
limited clothing that i have here right
and i'm picking up this t-shirt she goes
what about ariella grande and i was like
and i swear to god i was just picking it
up do you like ariana grande who doesn't
i don't know one song she sings oh you
have to watch her i'm stuck you know in
the 70s and 80s some 90s she has a gift
there's this youtube video of her i
think that's on jimmy fallon and she can
do
celine dion she can do everybody all
these
yeah just move it closer to you is this
gonna be a thing well if you keep
turning and talking to ryan it will be
well ryan's interesting guy he's a
handsome dude yeah he is
it seems interesting bobby lee said he
looked like an eagle from the side
[Music]
but go ahead no but i was literally
picking this t-shirt up from the stack
and when when her mobile i said so it
was like had to i had to wear this well
i like it thank you it's it's thinning
black's thinning
right and she's upside down which makes
it work
it does somehow is there i don't know if
there's a reason but ariana grande i
know a lot of listeners
how do you know
how do you not know one song from ariana
grande that's okay that you don't it's
like
meeting someone who's never watched
seinfeld you know when you meet them and
you're just like you are so lucky and
i'm not saying you have to buy her
albums no offense ariana or why i'm
looking at you but
um
but like watch that youtube video of her
doing other people's voices she's
amazing have you listened to any aria
grande songs yeah no i mean i am one of
those like it's
how do you not run across an ariana
grande song i i wouldn't know who
you probably would know
thank you next
i got one last problem without you sing
something
i'm so [ __ ] grateful for my see
that's better see i couldn't do that and
i'm wearing her t-shirt did she say the
f-bomb songs yeah isn't she really young
i mean she's like 29 now
young to you
speaking of which we're getting old man
i mean
you look the same no no you have more
hair i absolutely don't look the same i
i sometimes i find it hard to look in
the mirror in the mornings i i honestly
get up and i try not to look at myself i
try to shower i try to blow dry really
quick
uh i air dry what about your hair today
i gave a chest a little trim hair
trimming
i remember you having a lot of shaving
considerations
on the smallville well not just your
head but you'd be like how's my back
how's it you know well you know it's
like sometimes your back my neck
and but sometimes
do you ever you don't have any hair on
your back
not that i can see you really are so
lucky do you know how lucky you are to
not have any hair it's not like i'm
heralding the hendersons
but but but i get some if i let it go
for a couple months i need somebody to
trim it with an electric razor yeah see
i don't know how lucky i am because i
haven't you know what i mean so you
don't do any trimming does your wife ask
you to trim down there below the waist i
mean there's always a little bit of a
look like it's not like a direct request
but there's always a little bit like hey
you know clean it up in general
oh so she says something well just like
about a lot of things you know like
clean it up it's like clean it up clean
it up just clean it up what about you
ryan does amanda ever ask you to uh trim
down stairs uh no but it's yeah it's
it's implied just sort of keep it keep
it nice i can't find it i can't find it
it's too hairy that's the yeah that's
the ongoing it's a lot smaller than a
lot of my hairs well listen i think we
should start now and i just want to say
thank you for pay thank you for paying
me to be here
absolutely i always have to pay my
guests to be here otherwise why would
they spend so much valuable time with me
uh you know i got this family feud game
really quick and it's kind of fun so
each of you you get three strikes but uh
top six answers on the board ryan and
tom name something you'd find on a
playground one at a time so go ahead jim
jungle jim you're correct that's the
number four answer uh ryan swing set
that's the number one answer tom
damn you took mine we have to keep going
i thought i got one there's six answers
on the board this is family feud here um
i don't know what a lot of things are
called there um
monkey bars correct that's one ryan
three left oh slide
sly two answers left on the board what
would you find in a playground come on
rappers
no food who goes to playgrounds children
there we go that's the number six answer
and one left
this is probably the best there's
usually more than one slide
no but this is not a slide this is uh
you know it's kind of a balancing thing
it's kind of like
oh it's seasonal yeah this is where it
is
i have two sons now and i think they've
they've like
gotten the seesaws out of the uh why is
that why do they get see-saws out of
them there might be a liability issue i
just we've been i go to parties as much
as i can i've
very rarely because kids kind of fl you
know when they're up they kind of fall
down they could hit their heads i could
see the liability issue
are you
now that you're a dad you have two kids
now right yep you have rocklin
yep thompson rocklin thompson and
thompson and rocklin two boys two boys
how much has your life changed honestly
um you've gotta be [ __ ] exhausted
dude two kids
you had your own [ __ ] going on you could
wake up when you want you could do what
you want now you're not doing that i
text you once at 4 30 in the morning
because i was on the east coast and you
were up
[Laughter]
you're like what are you doing up i'm
like why i don't know i mean
it's worth it man like you're i mean
there is alright well cut the [ __ ]
it's worth its stuff it's god it is it
is like it'll be 4 30 in the morning and
your son is like
da da da da and you're like
yeah like you're happy
and then you go and you sit down and
maybe you're trying to keep them
you know if they're not looking at you
and talking to you but they're engaged
something else you're like
you know yeah but it's it is
it's the most special thing in the world
and and
yeah i recommend it for you
like i've said you gotta find the right
person yeah [ __ ]
story of my life dude but how long am i
you're always exhausted everybody knows
are you who me no everybody who has kids
who's listening or watching this like
you're exhausted but it's worth it i'm
exhausted right now you are but i'm
happy and that's the difference you know
when you do something you're jet lagged
you're doing something you don't want to
do well then you're completely miserable
but i mean i couldn't be happier right
now but this is you have purpose do you
feel like you have purpose in your life
now yeah a different kind of purpose
that i probably never would have had
otherwise yeah and what would you notice
a big change in your personality because
i remember on set
you could be you could be impatient yeah
you know you were kind of like always
working you could get a little revved up
but like does this force you to kind of
become more patient
a buddy of mine gave me really good
advice when when my wife was pregnant
with her first son he's like um
you're gonna realize that you have zero
tolerance for [ __ ] once your child
is born and i was like what do you mean
and he's like once that kid's born like
you're just gonna like your friends who
are sort of like
i'll be there but i'll be late but you
just you don't give a [ __ ] like it's
just not important anymore but your kids
are and keeping them safe is good which
is why when you then leave your children
those choices to do that are so much
more important like coming here
i had to think you know is this worth
leaving my children for
well you're only a minute away
but um but it's a consideration with
work projects and and things that you
like we're working on two things right
but like those feel worth it to me to
spend time away from my family in order
to
be creative and do great things to come
back to them do you feel like you need
to like sometimes getting away going to
a convention going to shoot a movie
going to do these things it's almost
like ugh i needed this
i thought i did um as you know
um
there was a conv there was a 10-day
10-day period where i went to a
convention had a couple days off and i
met you at another convention what not
and
you know all i i thought i was gonna be
like okay i'm free because i hadn't been
i hadn't left my family like a year and
a half and there was a part of me that
was like okay man finally i get to sleep
well we go into the convention there's
there's a lot of work very little sleep
but then the three days i had to myself
the first night i slept 14 hours and you
hadn't slept 14 hours since probably
thompson was born i've never slept 14
hours i don't think ever
and then i was like cool i'm gonna do
this for two more nights well it doesn't
happen that way i mean your body can't
really do that
but i
honestly all i did was miss them the
entire time really yeah i couldn't
because you could easily come on here as
many do and you could say oh kids are
wonderful kids you know i had my friend
chris once said to me he's like no
matter what anybody ever says to you and
i love my child i love my child more
than anything sometimes
you want to [ __ ] kill the kid there
well i've never
he's like but obviously you don't but
there's times you're like i can't make
you happy there's times when you just
want your kid to do what you want them
to do and that's like go to sleep or
like
there is that stuff but i've never
i've never thought about killing my
child well i don't think he meant
killing the child i thought i think he
meant just like i just i just [ __ ]
can't make you happy there's some times
where you're like i just wish i could go
take a nap or i wish i could just have
an hour to myself there is that i mean
that's normal that's normally human
being and that's where you know like my
wife and i we we we juggle that you know
so does having kids affect your
relationship does it make it is it more
positive
uh things or does it sometimes there's
like you know when are we gonna have
because i remember you telling me
something like you know she's got two
kids in her hand and you're kind of like
looking at her like hey happy time what
do you think she's like i got two
[ __ ] kids in my arms
how are we gonna have time for this but
there's gotta be things that you you
know you gotta make time for the two of
you that is something which i'm still
trying to get better at i mean that's
just how it goes but we both enjoy our
kids so much like all we do like when
our kids are there we just look at each
other and smile like it's awesome
inside of you is brought to you by m1
finance there's a reason they call m1
finance the finance super app this
all-in-one app makes it easy as pie to
invest borrow and spend exactly how you
want
build a portfolio of stocks or etfs in
minutes with their intuitive pies
interface or use a pre-build expert pie
that invests according to your goals
investing involves risk and m1 helps you
invest according to your risk tolerance
borrow against your portfolio with some
of the lowest rates on the market then
use it however you want keep in mind
borrowing increases your risk and rates
may vary or stash your cash in their
free digital checking account it's fast
it's easy and it saves you tons of time
and time
is money switch to a sleeker easier and
better way to manage your money plus get
a 30 bonus to your m1 invest account
when you get approved and fund it with 1
within your first 14 days
go to m1finance.com
inside of you for more info that's m as
in michael the number one finance.com
terms and conditions apply inside of you
is brought to you by fairway oh boy
fairway is a family-owned grocery chain
and a top ten employer in iowa that has
been in business since 1938 they have
over 12 000 employees and service six
states with brick and mortar locations
before launching fairway meat market to
service the rest of the us the fairway
meat department has always been
considered the backbone of their
operation what customers can expect from
fairwaymeatmarket.com
it's still hand cut by fairway butchers
to ensure the best possible quality it's
the same quality that they promise at
the counter now delivered to your home
nationwide there's nothing better man
than getting a big box of fresh
freaking meat from fairway
um i love it they sent me a big box a
while back
and uh just absolutely delicious and uh
cheaper than you get at the store you
know they give you a good deal fairway
meat markets quality meat comes straight
from america's heartland each and every
cut is done by their highly experienced
team of butchers to ensure you get the
same quality they put into every
in-store customer experience and people
love the wide selection of products
fairway offers ribs to rib eyes pork
chops and beef tenderloin they have
every style and cut your kitchen can
handle this week my listeners can get
the butcher's holiday collection listen
to this the butcher's holiday collection
valued at 275
for just
169.99 plus free shipping when entering
inside at checkout the butcher's holiday
collection package includes two 12-ounce
usda choice ribeye steaks two
eight-ounce usda choice filet mignons
two eight ounce usda choice sirloin
fillets
four eight ounce one hundred percent
full blood wagyu patties
doesn't it taste delicious
six eight ounce certified duroc boneless
pork chops two pounds of private labeled
bacon all for
169.99 the butcher's holiday collection
and you get free shipping when entering
inside at checkout that's more than 100
off the best meat in america this
holiday season plus free shipping
nationwide that's fairwaymeatmarket.com
promo code inside and look for the
butcher's holiday collection codes give
free shipping site-wide as well not just
on the select package
i have to say ryan i mean tom definitely
is more of a calmer
patient person than i knew him on
smallville
just in the last since the kids were
born especially you do seem more like
you kind of go with the flow well i did
an interview
um recently for the 20th anniversary of
smallville and i talked to this it was
over the phone the guy couldn't even see
me and it was like a 15-minute interview
and at the end he's like you sound
really happy
and i was like
i am happy i mean this is great he goes
no no i interviewed you like four or
five times before during smallville
you this is the first time you've heard
i've heard you sound happy and i was
like wow you're right i mean there was
i don't want to complain but like that
was a there was a that was a tough part
of my life and
great success great tv show like very
grateful and all that but but on the
personal side i wasn't happy but i
remember that i remember it's funny
because now your parents visit and they
kind of take care of the kids and stuff
but i remember i don't know if i really
looked at you and your mother and father
as close when we were on smallville
you seem kind of distant and now when i
see you together
it seems like there's a new bond well my
it was funny my parents came to visit me
on smallville and
it's you know they they arrived i didn't
get home till like midnight i left at
6am they weren't awake it took two days
for them to come visit set and like you
and i have talked up people come to
visit you and set
and you start to shoot a scene and like
15 minutes later they're like
so um
you're still shooting this doing this
like it's very boring to visit set after
15 minutes and so my parents after three
days of that were like so we're gonna go
to vancouver island we're gonna smoke
off my parents took a vacation to visit
me and then took a vacation from
visiting me because i wasn't available i
mean i was gone all the time right so
that's probably why you didn't
necessarily see us together because i
was the show was everything at that
point it really was everything and it's
hard for people to understand they're
like you know they're probably like you
know
do they need to understand but i think
you know i think people in general
when you're filming something and you
don't text back and you don't you're
absorbed you're enveloped in a project
that you just you can't like for me i
can't
break away from it i've got to have full
focus on something or i'm not going to
be good right i've got to focus entirely
on the task at hand
and some people can get annoyed like you
haven't called me you didn't text me
back oh my friends will always give my
friend kent in indiana oh really when i
don't respond oh good talk dude well i i
went through a couple of friends during
that period but
but the friends that are still there are
still like my good friends like you go
into a submarine for 10 months
yeah you're basically just incommunicado
and people get that and you come back
out and it was like you know you you'd
have a month and a half or two to like
hang out with these people and then
you're like later and they're like later
see in a year
that's just
that's also good friendship i think yeah
i mean
do you need to talk to him every day
hopefully not know what you do
i facetime him hey ryan you're like hey
dude you facetime everyone i know
facetiming
20th anniversary of smallville you and i
just did a bunch of press we promoted
the blu-ray that's coming out yeah this
will probably be already out by the time
this airs yeah but um
and you always get offended upset when
people say 20th anniversary and you're
like it's not from the time it ended
it's from the time it started
20 years
20 years since you started smallville
and i've talked to you about this how
much do you think
if you when you look back at
starting the show
i mean it's got to be a daunting thing
or were you just so naive and just young
and giddy and all that that you just
didn't realize what a daunting task it
was to play the lead role in a huge
series well
the funny thing is i was sold on the
idea that it was ensemble
ensemble means there was a rest of the
cast to do some of the work so that was
the naivete that you're talking about to
me it was a it was a job cool i've never
been to vancouver let's go and then i
got in front of all you guys and you
guys knew what like
marks were and
where like how where the light should be
and stuff and i was like oh boy i better
i better learn fast so yeah i had no
idea i just knew
it was a great job
and i hope it would work and that's how
it continued
and we ended up lasting 10 years i mean
that was a yeah i think there's less
than 30 tv shows in the history of
television is that true
wow it's not a lot were you nervous
though honestly were you
acting for the like really for the first
time you've done some small things but
like doing scenes in the very beginning
do you remember how you felt do you
remember overwhelmed do you remember
like can i do this can i can i get
through it where were you embarrassed at
all the crews watching the cast
everybody were you because you're so
young and you just had to do something
done some modeling and like you did the
amy show
judging amy but you hadn't done a lot
well i would have been a nervous wreck
she was a that that judging amy
experience was awesome for me because i
got to act with her
and i saw the way she operated on set
and how she treated people and how when
the camera started and i don't know if i
knew this at the time but then she would
like
then we would just be in the scene it
would just be talking to each other a
lot like you and i did right and
in some ways when smuggled happened
again i thought it was
i thought it was an ensemble
but many times especially in the first
season i'm like where's everybody else
yeah michael was just here and he left
listen's now here she left right they
must be doing other things right no they
went home um but
the camera
i don't mean to sound like whatever but
the camera never never bothers me never
has never has like i don't see it
and and thank god that's rare it's rare
i'm just
think even in the beginning even when
you're first doing these few scenes you
aren't thinking oh my god am i selling
it am i doing the right thing am i no if
anything else i never felt like i
i i looked to
like the directors and producers or the
other actors
and be like did i not that i get away
with that but like when they move on i'm
like okay i don't know if it's good or
not but i wasn't like
oh no
because i just thought that other people
should tell me if i was doing bad news
yeah i don't know and we that our
relationship was a little bit like that
where you'd we'd be in a scene he'd be
like just do that again do that again
like you can do better or whatever like
that that was helpful and i was like
okay cool but i kind of looked for other
people to guide me innately so
you know if somebody was like
that was shitty i was like okay well how
do we adjust it right and i don't know
where i got that from or what not i
don't know if
i don't want to be arrogant and say i
don't know if you can teach that i was
just so focused on the job
that i don't know if so you've never
really cared about what other people
think is what you're saying well i cared
about the people around me who thought
but like as we've talked about social
media wasn't a thing or commenting about
episodes wasn't really right but you
know if there were times where you you
know we would
i just relied on other people i think
that's the answer i rely on other people
to help to support me and if they said
we needed more i'll do more they said we
got it we got it do you remember the
first time you saw
the pilot or some moments that you
thought
wow this is gonna change my life
um i don't remember seeing the pilot you
don't remember seeing the pilot i know
what the pilot is right but i don't know
where i was and when i saw it i don't
but you got to remember like the first
time you watched an episode of
smallville that you were the lead in it
and thought you had different you get
thoughts about it i just don't remember
when or where i was but i do remember
when clark pulls off in the pilot when
he pulls off the door to the truck
and he says uh
you know my name's clark kent you're in
smallville
i remember doing that scene and being
like oh this is awesome
like this is this is like james bond
indiana jones it's like there was just
so much about that moment you know um i
just remember when we were doing it i
remember being
i remember it being cool yeah you were
so young so like i i mean you
also you didn't have time to go home and
study lines
no now that's got to be terrifying sort
of for someone
like me
who always studied lines and did plays
and you know had to really learn the
stuff so i could be free on set but you
you just didn't have the time you're in
every scene every day you could you had
to go home and sleep but that was my job
my job was to be there all the time
every day
um
as you know with clark and lex like
clark doesn't have a lot of lines and a
lot of times in television shows the
leads don't because the story needs to
be
you know they're in the middle of the
story so this you know everybody else
talks to them it's a lot at the times
what happens in television shows um
so like
you know you and i would be in scenes
and i'd be like man you know you got a
ton of lines like it's you you you you
and then right clark would be like what
do you mean
but my job was to be there all the time
innocent and and i always
you know for 10 years my life it was
whatever it takes to be there that's
just was my focus did you ever have
breaking points where you're like i
can't freaking do this i'm i'm so tired
they've got to give me a day off um did
you ever have moments where you're
driving to work and you're just like i
got to pull over i'm so tired i mean
i'll be honest it was most days
like it was most days because we drove
ourselves to work yeah until the cast
got together yeah and said tom has to be
the driver he's going to die he's going
to die he's your lead role he's our lead
guy
you so many times you were driving to
work and you had to pull over
i i got pulled over once
by a cop by a cop
um i was going to work i was just in a
constant like irritated mood all the
time and i remember one day i was
driving to work like season three
and it was like
i'm sure some of some of you listening
are watching this
a car is slowed in front of you you want
to just not slow down
you hit the horn
the car clears and you realize like
someone just got an accident there's a
cop already there and the cop just
turned to me and was like turn up like
so i pulled over and the guy was like
what are you honking for and
in vancouver honking your horn
canadians don't honk they don't hunt
so they're canadians they're lovely and
i'm not a big honker but it was just
that moment i was like
oh
he's what are you holding for i'm like i
just
i'm he and he he made me sit there for a
minute to almost teach me like
calm down slow down never give me a
ticket but i you know i mean i needed to
hear that right there yeah like just
chill out a little bit but you were
absolutely you'd say at least once or
twice a week on the way to work or on
the way home you're just like i'm out of
my mind tired yeah constantly like did
you fall asleep easy did you ever need
any pills to go to sleep never pills
never
beer what i did is i would normally nap
for 15 minutes at lunch like
i would
like during lunch
i would have i would get my lunch eat it
while i was walking get to my trailer
lay down
15 minutes later get up and the second
part of my day was always more
productive i felt right just from a nap
you know harry truman used to nap he
said just in a box of shorts a pair of
boxers and a t-shirt and take a little
30-minute power nap and it used to make
his day that's what he did i still love
naps do you still nap even with kids you
can nap when i can even 15 minutes
anything i'm sure jess goes just go take
a nap just go check him out
a lot of times i'll be like i just need
like 10-15 minutes and she knows i'll be
back but what about the pressure of like
always being in shape like getting
bigger like getting stronger losing
weight like did you have to deal with a
lot of that stuff well at the time
because of my age it wasn't a big deal
um and what we did with clark is clark
wasn't gonna be a guy who would take his
shirt off if you know what i mean unless
it like the action made it happen right
like your shirt was off quite a few
times but not as much as you think i'll
have to go back because i remember being
like is it really worth it because i
never had the time to work out like we
see these movies and all these guys now
they make time for that right um
what was i gonna do work out
five minutes a day and half hour on the
weekends like but you look good because
you were young i was young yeah but did
you do push-ups in your trailer did you
sometimes it weights like maybe before
like an actual scene right i would try
to get a little pump or something
um but it was really just
you were lucky genetics genetics yeah
but i remember there was one season
where you just kind of were like over it
you came back and you just had eaten
[ __ ] everything in sight and the
producers summer
what happened
it was just there was a little
conversation and it was steve wardrobe
was like what happened
and i was like what do you mean i
finally had fun for the first time in my
life away from the show
but i gained a few pounds and by the way
it wasn't like i came back 300 pounds i
just came back like
a little bit more right and so
i don't know if anything was adjusted or
not but there was just a little bit of a
you know let's clean it up let's clean
it up who said it to you ow
it had to be out i'm pretty sure it was
steve al would ne i don't know steve the
wardrobe guy i said uh you need to do
something yeah he told you yeah and you
were like what do you mean well i knew
what he meant
i was like you're right how many
episodes did it take you to get back
into the shape you needed to be in i i
don't recall but i think it was a couple
weeks because you have to understand
being on the show you lose weight
there's no time to eat there's no time
to do anything so it's like you lose
weight just being the lead on a show
right i mean unless you're going back
eating a box of donuts in your trailer
but
maybe some guys don't know you were
always pretty good with your diet and
stuff though right yeah i ate pretty
well
i mean you had demands
i mean i just
i mean i wasn't eating pizza and stuff
but
you know chicken and salad you know i'm
just clean like that's what i like to
eat
inside of you is brought to you by my
good friends at better help better help
online therapy
boy i can't tell you how much this works
i get emails all the time thank you for
talking about better help thank you for
getting me into to therapy
ryan does better help i do
i just you know uh i just had a friend
this morning i was facetiming with him
and his wife said you know my kid's uh
dealing with depression
and uh do you know any of your
therapists i go better help online
therapy because they're in the middle of
sort of nowhere and you don't need to go
anywhere you can facetime or text or you
know it's it's better help is just it's
amazing it just helped you out yeah it's
uh it's convenient
yeah it has been good i have gotten a
lot out of it well i like that look
whether you're struggling with grief
relationships or stress or having
trouble sleeping or meeting goals online
therapy might be for you better help is
secure online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with a
licensed professional
therapists betterhelp will assess your
needs and match you with your own
accredited therapist you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours and
you don't have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room
therapists have a broad range of
expertise which may not be available in
your area
the service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime folks send a message to your
therapist you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change therapists if
you need and that may happen you know
you meet someone the first time you may
not vibe with them you change your
therapist better help it's that easy
and i i completely recommend this
so many people have told me it works
it's more affordable than traditional
offline therapy by a landslide if you
ask me and financial aid is available
visit betterhelp.com
inside and join over the 2 million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using better help ryan
that they are recruiting additional
therapists in all 50 states
inside of you is sponsored by better
help and our listeners get 10 off their
first month of online therapy at
betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp.com
inside give it a shot
better help inside of you is brought to
you by my good friends at sonos uh
you've heard me talk about this boy is
this the best holiday gift holiday treat
if you don't have sonos i have had sonos
in my house for 18 years before these
guys even became a sponsor
and uh it's pretty amazing because
instead of having giant speakers and
amps and all these uh you know uh
receivers everywhere you just had this
small device that just sits in the back
that has great sound
sonos you could play a song in each room
a different song in each room you have a
party mode for outside you could listen
to
you know mazzy star up in the bedroom
you could listen to the beatles in the
basement it's really wonderful i love
sonos i'm so glad they're a sponsor i
hope they stick around and they'll stick
around if you guys purchase [ __ ] so
that's kind of the way uh look share the
joy of listening on sonos this season
make the sound system on your wish list
a reality with speakers and sound bars
that are easy to set up easy to use i do
it guys
and they all work together so you can
listen in any or any room or every room
like i talked about and bring the family
together with incredible sound for
everything for from classic carols to
festive films sonos works with all your
streaming services and control is simple
with the sonos app
your voice using amazon alexa or google
assistant and apple airplay 2.
spoil the listeners in your life with a
gift that keeps on giving boy boy does
it
treat gamers and movie lovers to an
immersive home theater experience with
beam
keep your fitness loving friends
motivated with great sound for their
workout playlists with move and help
relatives relax with hands-free control
of their music and more on sonos one i
love these guys i hope you'll check them
out it's easy you go to sonos s o n o s
dot com to learn more and wrap up your
holiday shopping that's sonos.com
[Music]
if you look back like which one of your
favorite episodes that you recall that
you're like you know what this is the
one i always remember well the easiest
one is transference that's when you
become evil clark no no it's not you
switch bodies you you talk you tell me
you do it i don't remember
it's lana luther and clark switch bodies
and so that's for me to play a character
that um
that uh
it's so iconic and i mean the glove we
love the gloves we love john glover um
i mean this guy is like
he's like an astronaut you know i mean
he's just like you can't yeah he's he's
superb so to play a character that he's
been playing in a sense it was it was a
it was a lot of fun
you switched you became leno luther he
became clark kent yeah and one of the
things and i think he'd enjoy the story
but he had more trouble playing clark i
think because clark is is more
his actions and the way he goes about is
very simple and maybe not as complicated
as lana luther or
laird and i remember john b
asking me to come to set and he was in
the prison
scene behind the bars and i was in the
next scene but
uh james marshall called me i think he
was directing one of the directions
yeah and he called me and he said can
you come to set and of course i'm like
i'm not supposed to
i don't need to be there for another 30
minutes and he's like no glover wants to
talk to you he wants your help and i was
like i'll be there in two seconds you
know
and i go in there and john's pacing in
this
literally in the cell
in this prison
and i'm like john what's up he's like oh
and he like grabs the bars and he's like
tom i need your help and i'm like
you need something to eat like what do
you mean he's like how do you do it i'm
like dude he goes play clarkett and i
was like what are you talking about he
goes i don't i just i don't know you
know he couldn't get he couldn't feel
like he could get there i go just
simplify things it's not all that
complicated i mean i can say that to a
guy like john because he's like so
talented right um
and he was like you don't understand i
complicate everything
and i was like just slow everything down
you're not so ahead of everything as you
normally may be
and he and i saw light in his eyes and
somehow that piece of
information or direction landed with him
right and i mean if you watch the
episode it's it's it's a lot of fun to
watch now what about the fact you told
me you tell the story tell the story
about the uh
it was one of the best it was written
about that was one of the best episodes
ever oh
and then something happened so so this
was written about in the publication
recently i believe yeah so the same
story came out on the same like we're
getting ready for this big 20th
anniversary since smallville started
um and we have a lot of press coming on
and people want to talk about which is
great so i found myself being like you
know what maybe i need to revisit some
of the information so i can have more
talking points from what i've just been
talking about before so i found this
website and i was like cool top 10
episodes of smallville and one of them
on there is the one about red kryptonite
and clark kind of goes bad and whatnot
and i'm so and and i texted you the list
because i was like oh i there's like two
episodes that you're very much featured
on too right just so that when you and i
are together we can talk kind of like
so anyway i'm like okay cool and then
there's this link on there and they're
like top 10 worst things about
smallville and i was like
i gotta click on that so i click on it
and the first one is how bad i was an
actor in that episode that was like one
of the best episodes and i was like this
is on the same website and i remember
talking to you about you know you can't
listen to stuff and i'm like i know i'm
not upset about it then you're like
you're talking about it
i'm like but i'm not upset i just i just
find it you know it's it's kind of
ironic it's it's it's just like it's one
of the best episodes ever ranked on
their site and then
it's the greatest messages
ever it just doesn't make any sense well
listen i mean it's just what it is and
that's what you gotta let i mean we
gotta let go as actors we can't it's
none of our business what other people
think about it okay but on the same note
i have a question for you i listened to
one of your episodes lately with the guy
from the flash no this is good okay you
guys are talking about how you can never
you can never allow yourself to really
enjoy your experience and and part of my
heart broke because it's like a lot of
actors go their whole career is never
able to enjoy anything they've ever done
and i don't think anyone's ever been
able to say
why you can
like it's it's you know i mean like a
lot of people go through their lives
just you know like i'm so miserable and
misery is such a motivation
um and i don't know how to get through
that but
i guess my point
i did that going through smallville and
now that time has passed i actually am
not able to appreciate it somehow right
and
i don't know you just spoke specifically
about how like you're never happy no i'm
sorry not then you're happy but like
when you perform you're like
it stresses me out i try i just want to
enjoy myself i i don't think i've ever
really there are moments when i'm really
comfortable on set and i enjoy things
but
overall i put so much pressure on myself
to be great that it's hard to enjoy what
you're doing when you just are always
striving to be great and not just
enjoying the moment i think that goes
with life it's like if you're not in the
moment how are you going to enjoy it
you're always ahead of yourself you're
stressing out about things and how do
you how do you deal with that well i you
know you brought up having kids my kids
have taught me how to be in the moment
because
i mean
when you're on set you're in the moment
because somebody says action or go and
you're you know you're there
and
if you're not there you you probably
don't stand a chance at least for that
scene or whatnot but with your kids and
maybe your frustrations building or this
and that but you're like but even my
wife has told me it's like it's all
temporary so it's going to change in
probably 15 minutes anyway whatever's
going on the happiness or the or the
frustration so just
just enjoy it because your kids are
going to grow and they're going to be
gone before you know it so that going
back to your earlier question about kids
like that's what it's teaching me
appreciate what's happening right now
whether it's good or bad right and i
think that's that's left out a lot about
appreciation like are you only supposed
to appreciate everything good about this
moment no
maybe appreciate what can you learn from
this moment i think is the way to get to
appreciation
somebody just ran into you in their car
there's a horrible example
but
yeah
but if somehow you can get to what can i
learn from this moment you you will
actually maybe be able to
be in the moment more i mean navigate
other moments so it's like you know what
take a deep breath
like being here i'm alive this is an
accident how do we deal with this you
know
there's there's a way of programming
to program your mind to make you sort of
not freak out about everything and that
goes with years of therapy and other
things like that yeah
um the ti no tights no flights now that
was something from the beginning that
you were like i'm clark kent
this is the story of clark kent and how
he becomes you know his is uh is growing
up and eventually becomes superman but
they made it clear to you and you said
hey i'm signing this contract because
i'm playing clark kent i'm not getting
in the tights right and they said
absolutely
how many times did they try to kind of
convince you like let's do it it's time
let's do it let's get in the tights well
there was never that conversation so the
conversation went yes i and going back
to your being so naive i was so naive
that i was just like
i had some
experience with contracts before and how
they can maybe
sound good and once you go through them
they they can work against you and so
with this one and i had other options at
the time
and i was like okay here's the deal like
i read the scripts kid in high school we
don't know who he's going to be
he and i never wanted really him to be
superman
um
so in my contract was i would never put
on the cape or the tides for the suit
i think it was like halfway through
season one they just put out a script
and clark's like flying around with a
suit on and stuff and i remember just
sort of
saying you know you guys know that
that's not gonna be me
like it's in my contract you said that
yeah and they were like okay and they
rewrote it i think they were just trying
to see if they could test the wall and
by the way if clark was in his suit
as superman season one we would have
never lasted ten years right because
that wasn't what the show is there's
lois and clark on these other shows that
that's what it's about it's about them
being in the suits and and and saving
the day right it was about clark and lex
and jonathan and lionel and martha and
all the other characters it was about
their journey of who they were gonna be
not who they are
um as far as at the end right if that
makes anything if you were to go back if
you can go back in time
and to the last episode
would you fly a little more no do you
want to be seen a little more no did you
think it was just enough yeah well i
i wrote that scene
really yeah the the final scene of the
when clark goes like this
that was i i had a conversation with
peter roth who's the the head of he was
the head of the right yep and um i was
my idea was i wanted this is how i felt
about the show ending is i wanted
i wanted to show clark ascending
but knowing that we can't go there but
in our hearts know that he was out there
and i got that from other shows that i
liked jack bauer did that in 24 maybe
that would love 24. i would go home to i
would race home to watch 24 while we
were shooting small jersey 24 iron yeah
you liked it with kiefer sutherland
who's now like kind of a friend of mine
and i still get nervous when i see him
you get starstruck i do
because i just and not because he's jack
power just because
you know when you invest
your time watching a show and then you
meet that person it's like
it's it's otherworldly a lot of times um
and i would race home this is before you
could just like download right you know
and all that other stuff so tivo i
believe even before that before it was
like it would air on fox on this night
and if you didn't if you weren't didn't
have like a tape recorder i mean this
was
yeah yeah um
but yeah that was that was my go-to so
anyway that inspired me a little bit and
i just wanted clark to live on but in
our hearts but
we couldn't see him go there as superman
right you know we're not going to talk
about it but you know a lot of people
have asked about the uh the animated
series the small animations that you and
i are working on and we will just say
that
it's been it's fun we're going to be
pitching you know uh in january warner
brothers and you know we've got some
great people attached and you know we're
hoping that they they bite and um what
can we say who's attached i mean
uh well alan miles the creators of
smallville and uh you know we're uh so
people ask me questions we don't have
any information for you other than we've
got a great pitch and uh we hope they
bite
that's all i'll say yeah i think i think
the the only thing we can say is that it
is moving forward which is a lot of fun
yeah yeah we talked about it actually
for a few years
and we're always talking about how cool
it would be at conventions and then we
were like you know this you know and
finally now it's coming to fruition yeah
but you know at least the uh the idea
and the artwork and yeah you know
but it's fun because you know doing
these conventions with you we've started
to like become better friends and not
only that but like you know then you
write a script and like we're you know
i'm pitching we're pitching it together
and uh we're trying to it's it's it's
nice to be working with friends it's
nice to be
um what's your experience with that
because you've never really worked with
friends before and stuff you usually
just uh actor for hire or a producer or
whatever well i think that yeah a lot of
times when you go to work you you
hopefully become friends with the people
right but there's an old hollywood
saying that it you know you hope to get
to a point in this industry where you
only get to work with your friends
because then you're really having fun
yeah and i think that's part of you know
the the shorthand that you and i have
allen miles i mean it's just so easy
and creative
it's exciting um and i and i think that
that's going to lend a lot of uh
energy to the project i think it does i
think it's just sort of like you know
like hey it's gonna be me and you on set
and we're gonna be able to hire people
if the show gets picked up and we get to
hire people that we like and work with
and there's there's this that's such an
appeal that's such a
i mean really living the life if you
could do that if you could hire the
people around you it's it i mean with
any job i'm sure everybody who's
listening or watching this you know you
know you have to go to work certain
people like and some people you don't
want to be around yeah and you it's a
lot of work to be around people that you
don't sort of measure with but then when
you get that person that you connect
with it's fun
yeah
the professionals
you and brendan fraser in in freaking
south africa yeah
you almost died
uh we i think
i don't think i was the only one i mean
we had
we we had armed security uh we weren't
allowed to leave the hotel on our own um
one of the crew cars got shot with like
a
uh ak 740 round because two taxi drivers
got in a fight it was
johannesburg is a very interesting place
and um did you know it was gonna be this
dangerous no
no were you scared for your life at
times i i was i mean i felt protected
because of
bodyguards the guys around me in the
armored car that i would go to set in
but onset
we would kind of shoot out the in the
boonies a little bit so i didn't feel
like we were a couple times we went into
the city and it it got a little a little
hairy but it added you know i'm trying
to be positive about it now but it added
to the energy of it but the idea when i
went down is my family would come and i
think within like two days i'm like yeah
that's not gonna you're not coming no
and how long were you gone
without seeing them three months without
seeing thompson was that the most
difficult thing you've had to endure
yeah i mean part of it he was and part
of it was he was so young at the time
you know i convinced myself that he
didn't know i wasn't there and my wife
did a great job she ended up flying out
to new york and being with my family
which was helpful as well
um but there were a couple days where it
was really tough but then
you know
most of the time you just focus on the
work and you know
it's just yeah it was tough i won't do
it again how was uh well what do you
mean you won't do it again because the
cw just picked up the professionals to
air on the cw yes now if it's a success
won't they want to do another series
most likely but there'll be some
adjustments to security and location and
duration
what was brendan fraser like to work
with
so
first of all amazing i mean his career
is just
on a yeah him he's working to take it
off he's working with your buddy
scorsese yeah um
yeah my good buddy scorsese old marty um
i was a fan of brendan
i mean everybody's a fan of brendan and
yeah and we get there and our characters
i'm supposed to play this military guy
who's only paid to protect him and
doesn't really care about him
and his character was written in a way
that should be that way but then brendan
shows up to set and he's so damn likable
and such a nice guy that i found myself
fighting
caring about him as my character would
you know i mean like in person him and i
got along great like it was like it was
seamless but i felt
i i was like i don't think my character
should like him all this much i don't
think he should be so at ease with him
and so it was like a it was like a fun
fight
right but he's just so
he's so good at what he does i mean when
does this air when is the professional's
aaron and ceo they haven't said
but they made an announcement because i
saw the other they bought it they don't
know when they're gonna air it and you
guys should watch the professionals
there's a trailer out for it it looks
pretty crazy it looks like you had it in
an intense shoot we so it doesn't look
like it was fun
it was fun once we started rolling
right if you know what i mean yes yes
getting to set being away from set was
all very uh
delusional
like you just you didn't know where you
were in time and space or or
sort of what was going on but once you
started filming the whole cast and crew
was fantastic but there was one of our
characters who he's walking down so
basically think of the whole crew is on
this side right and they're filming this
way and they're walking down a
a like a well an african dirt road and
this guy's a band he doesn't know where
he is and he's walking around it's kind
of funny it's action funny is what this
thing
and literally dude without anybody
knowing it
a giraffe comes out
like 50 feet behind him on onto the dirt
road and the actor ken who's this
fantastic actor turns around and sees a
giraffe
and uses it and just starts being like
he kept it yeah and he's like this is
how crazy it is that i crash landed and
i'm just walking on this dirt road and
i'm seeing this in in real time well in
the i watch the um you watch the pilot i
watch the film
because i'm one of the producers as well
and i was like i remember calling one of
their producers because i wasn't there
that day and i was like how did you get
that giraffe to do that they're like oh
we
that was not a plan
but this actor turned around saw a
giraffe and just stayed with us stayed
with it and this guy ken i mean he's a
german guy
he's
a fantastic actor he speaks like five
languages and he dubs his charac he's a
german actor
he will he dubs his performances
in like french italian and english and
obviously he speaks in german or like
nobody else dubs him in other countries
he dubs he does himself he dubs himself
like that's how that's crazy and he's a
great actor yeah
do you still love acting yeah
you love it you love being on set you
love acting there's
you know
there's there's a thing about being on a
television show and fighting the the
repetitive repetitiveness
competitiveness i can't believe i said
it thank you for saying it
that's part of the job is that part
but there's those times where you nail a
scene or you're just in a moment and you
walk away and like
you can't go to sleep it's like a drug
you know it's like and
you know you you may not get that all
the time but you strive for that but
when you nail it like it's just like
it's a visceral but you definitely want
to act for the rest of your life you
like that you you love doing it you want
it you you it excites you yeah the idea
of it yeah
not the idea of it i mean something like
that but like
like it's not like
because some people never want to do it
again because some people just like you
know i have a friend who's always just
like i don't care what i'm doing i just
as long as i'm acting where i'm not like
that exactly i i don't want to do
anything yeah you know i've heard you on
your podcast have this discussion before
yeah no i mean i have right and i and i
get that you don't live for it and
that's fine but when some when something
comes along that you have to i could see
you immediately jumping up and getting
right into it yeah and i think that's
true that's okay that's why you see also
you see a lot of actors
who when they find success you see them
for like five six years
not to say it's not 10 or whatever but
they like bust it out and then you don't
see them for a while well because maybe
they're living their life again or now
they're being more taking a break
because they can or what not but
i mean the the two projects that you and
i have going you'd be out of your seat
in two seconds to do just like i would
so sure for sure but that's because it's
meaningful to you it's meaningful that's
exactly right [ __ ] talking with tom
welling uh these are questions oh good
we're almost done well geez she you know
that's the end well no but these are my
top tier patrons if you want to give
back to the podcast if you're enjoying
the podcast if you like it you want to
become a patreon patreon.com inside of
you it's awesome i'm a member he's a
member there's a lot of patrons and they
really get back to the podcast and i
couldn't do this show without them but
here is the first question raj says
what's the longest you went wearing the
same underwear during the pandemic
oh i'm not that guy um you change your
underwear every day i mean if not twice
yeah i'm not a i'm i get
yeah you're not disgusting
no like i don't like being interesting
i'm not like weird about being clean but
like i i yeah i don't yeah i've been
stuck traveling
and like oh man i only brought one pair
of socks and i'm here for three days and
then you're like in the sink
and you put them in the sunshine to get
the the scent off i have i've done
things get musty they get moldy i keep
myself clean yeah well that starts with
trimming down there like we talked about
in the very beginning of this uh episode
dana asks as an adult what is the most
childish thing you catch yourself doing
childish i mean
enjoying playing with your kids because
it's like you get to play with toys
i mean like there's i mean if like
burping and farting it's not but i don't
like enjoy that i mean as much as you do
who does but childish thing of just like
there's times when like when you have
kid kids you you start to evaluate what
you do with your time and how much like
there is that sort of thing and there's
times where i i'll i'll be sitting there
watching something on tv or or doing
nothing i'm like i'm literally wasting
my time right now
but i sometimes you need to waste your
time but isn't there something like
i don't play video games you don't play
video games like i collect horror
posters and memorabilia and things like
that is there any kind of like little
thing you do like that you don't really
you never kept anything off the set you
never brought anything home and you know
what i i i wish i did but then i did a
show like lucifer whereas their first
season i didn't take any from that like
it does it doesn't interest you it i
don't it doesn't occur to me i almost
need someone to tell me to do it because
when i'm at work i'm just thinking about
that i'm not thinking about after work
right i mean it's
it's not even a consideration but like
you know now that i have kids it's like
it'd be really cool to have some of that
stuff
um but again that's not for me it's for
them so i don't know if that's a
difference do you like being an adult do
you ever like
wish that you were young again do you
ever wish you were like a teenager do
you ever like or you're just like i'm
moving forward
i mean
i'm very fortunate that
i'm happier now than i've ever been and
i'm not just saying that that's amazing
like even like people are like
the slippery slope of what would you
have done differently i mean there's a
shitload i would do i would do
differently but only if it got to
got me to where i am now
if you know that you wouldn't want to
change anything that would alter who you
are if i could skip a couple things or
change in other things but then be right
here right now i would do that
you know what i mean i mean there's a
million things we would change
but then
i'm in a happy place if i wasn't in a
happy place i'm sure i could just go off
you could riff
you're just [ __ ] real i could
probably ref yeah
bob k
what classic film would you love to
remake as an actor or director it's
funny i tried to remake a classic film
ray leota did a movie called no escape
i remember that movie in the 90s and i
spent about two years trying to remake
that and it
in a different way the problem was you
can't remake that movie as it is now you
have to update it right and we couldn't
cry we couldn't quite crack
how it would be different to remake it
but um that and i'm a big fan of
westerns like
anyway would you do a western in a
second yeah that'd be great
westerns are so clear like they're so
cinematic and since i'm so clear as far
as right and wrong and moral
and you know obviously a lot of that's
been changed i mean they redid the
magnificent seven recently it didn't
work
because they they just got away from the
core element of what a western is
um they probably got away from character
and likability it just became
celebrity like everybody looking good
everybody being macho yeah and if you go
back to seven samurai which that is
basically you know the original
magnificent stuff is based on
it's it's all characters japanese film i
recommend it
what uh nico what age would your kids
need to be before you ask michael to
babysit them
nico you son of a [ __ ] i'd probably ask
my kids to babysit you first that could
probably be the way to go yeah i think
i'd be a great babysitter you'd be fine
i mean you can't breastfeed right now
that's one thing with the younger one
tom you and thompson would have a blast
you guys he's the funniest person he is
hilarious you're this you're the second
funniest person i thought you were the
first
he's now you're the second my son is so
funny you want to hear a funny story yes
this literally happened the other day
you can cut this if it's not funny
so i'm a member of a golf course here um
in los angeles i'm there with my wife my
three-month-old and my almost
three-year-old son thompson
and we're there with some other friends
joe pesci who i told you made me late
the other day to meeting you right he
comes over
because we're all friends he's a golf
buddy man he comes over hey tommy how
you doing hey jessica you know
and my son is standing
painting just like on paper he goes hey
kid how you doing and my son looks up
and joe's wearing like this like a not a
like a baller's cap and he's smoking a
cigar my son looks up he goes what are
you a cowboy
oh my god and joe looks at me goes what
are you a wise guy
no
it was like one two and my son just
starts drawing again
everybody else
just [ __ ] dies
i've never said to my son what are you a
cowboy i have no idea where he gets that
he looked at your passion he goes what
are you a cowboy
it was you a wise guy totally
totally were you dying dude we were all
like that's joe
joe was
he laughed in his way like yeah he
thought it was good well he just loves
kids are you painting your thing you're
throwing offensive comments it's so
completely honest you know what i mean
kids are so honest
but anyway so
that's what i said like the funny thing
and my son is
i just i can't get enough of it he's
amazing lee anne p says what lessons has
being a dad taught you i mean you've
answered that in so many ways well i one
of them is patience one of his is like
time and uh
like scheduling but also like prior
priorities because i have a tendency
that i can spin out
um
and not spin out no way like when we
moved
i found myself trying to do like 10
things in one day
and my wife was like okay let's just
slow down a little bit let's prioritize
and one of the things she said she's
it's going to take a year for us to move
into this house all right so let's just
focus on you know this room or this that
we kind of you know
we have a lot outside we're like we're
going to wait to do that we're gonna
wait for the garage we just prioritized
and so i think i've gotten better at
that because i have a tendency to try to
like
do 10 things at once and anything you
read about being productive tells you
you can only do one thing at one time
like every book says that same thing
yeah um
however there's a lot of things wrong
with me
or that are
slightly on how healthy in life that
totally work on set
juggling 15 things at once focusing
moving on yeah there's something about
that that kind of works on your side
there is that thing and that's
that's why like some
some people can really do well on set
and can't do one life and vice versa and
then you get people like tom hanks
like they can do everything so i don't
know you know what would be fun which
probably will never happen i don't think
it would ever happen but to get together
with the entire cast
for like a dinner or something or a
gathering wouldn't that be fun
i mean i haven't seen instead of barb it
was kind of a burp i tried to what's the
what's the word i tried to hide it
swallow stifle stifle
hide yes all those things
but i always thought that would be kind
of cool to see
john and annette and glover and uh
kristen and you and me and a couple
other cast members to just you know to
just sort of be in a room together it's
been so long well part of the fun thing
we just did it recently we saw alan and
sam who i mean i haven't seen him since
johan richton who was aquaman on the
show and um we saw sam jones jack he's
going to be jack reacher creature um
and it's it's like it's so funny how you
pick up right where you where you
stopped and it's like
sitting down at dinner would i don't
know maybe not dinner but maybe drinks
in a bar atmosphere running into each
other it's so much fun because there's a
there's a there's a
i've said this before to you i don't
know if it was on this podcast or not
but
there is a trust that is like forged on
set that doesn't go away yeah like
there's other actors that you meet and
because you worked with this person you
can walk right up them and talk to them
and you haven't seen them forever yeah
and then that's true and then like their
husbands or their wives are like who the
[ __ ] is this guy who just walked up and
you're talking to like this do you who
do you miss the most that you haven't
seen in a long time that you like you
like seeing them or you'd like to just
at least or that person
probably i've really only seen schneider
once yeah and i just he was such a big
part of mine and clark's journey
um you know the the hand on the shoulder
and
that was all his thing the whole john
wayne yeah yeah um so yeah
schneidy schneidy i'd like to see a net
it's been a long time since i've seen a
net i mean i wouldn't it's not that i
wouldn't want to see any of them it's
hard to prioritize yeah it's true it's
like what's your favorite movie like i
don't have favorites yeah well you do
you sit across from them
but um
but look we do the cons together we do
these smallville nights if you guys ever
get a chance to come out uh and visit uh
we're doing one this podcast will
probably be be
aired
after like that but we have more to do i
mean we have yeah we have other cons
that we go so look us up and come to a
smallville nights come see us we always
have a lot of fun what's what's the most
thing what the biggest thing you love
about going to the cons um
so i spent a lot of years on smallville
we dealt with a lot because the show was
successful we were you know we were
asked to do a lot of press and one of
the things about press is like they're
always trying to kind of like
find out what's bad or you know trying
to they're trying to figure out who you
are when i you know i don't find myself
all that interesting or don't feel like
i have a lot to share but when you go to
the cons you're meeting fans and they
they express you what the show meant to
them in their own way
and it's like
it's it's awesome like i just want to
hear their stories i mean and especially
a show like smallville which you know
people watch with their parents or their
dads their moms and some of those people
now don't have their moms and dads or
whoever they watch it with and they're
there and they share that story and it's
so moving because
we weren't thinking about that when we
were filming or when we meet service
members who i remember this one guy in
an airport came up to me and he said
fatigues and i don't know if he was
coming home or going overseas and he was
like hey man you're that smallville guy
and i was like uh i mean yeah
he goes man i got to tell you my sister
sent me a box of dvds and that was the
last goddamn [ __ ] we watched but man we
enjoyed it thank you and i was like
what
thank me i mean i got chills right now
i'm like thank me something like thank
you and and it was
i'm glad they got to it yeah
yeah exactly but yeah but it distracted
them it's an escape
and uh that's what tv does that's what
movies do that's what entertainment does
so you know a lot of times we think
we're doing something that's trivial and
stupid and whatever and it's not a big
deal but it affects other people that's
how i feel about this
yeah
and i thank you for doing this
thank you for doing by the way i
probably asked you this a million times
but some time down the road if they
asked you to be
superman
i think you know there was a there's a
it wasn't especially during smallville
it wasn't about being superman or not it
was it was
it was only being clark kent on
smallville but they did some superman
movies they were never going to shut
down smallville for me to even do one
right right it's just a different thing
dc movies and dc television are very
different things and that's all fine
um
and then when things
when smuggled ended i was very anti
playing superman but now as i get older
i'm like oh maybe
i i mean
yes i think it would be fun and i think
i would like to think that i could add
an element that maybe hasn't been there
for a while as far as like maybe
superman's not so detached maybe he's
not such an alien maybe he's more maybe
there's an element of
you know my favorite scene is when
superman goes into the cafe doesn't have
his powers he gets beat up
then he comes back with his powers and
how does he and how he deals with that
right i think that
element
may need to
come back in a little bit and it'd be
fun and and again
you know i'm listen the other thing
about when your friends have kids they
just talk about your kids we had friends
over last night who have
similar age kids
we were like two hours into the night my
buddy's like so how are you
because it was just kids kids and it's
it's fantastic i could tell you had
plans by the way because i was just like
yeah so i'm in the area and you're like
alright cool see you tomorrow i'm like i
was gonna stop by tonight but
well i mean you're always welcome i know
i know i am but i think that having my
boys now i i
i kind of have to get over myself a
little bit like how cool would it be
for dad though to
but by the way how cool would it be
for all the people for for 10 years that
watched smallville and watched you
becoming
superman
over the years to down the road see that
superman now well that's that's a unique
thing that no one
can can do otherwise or have or have
done right playing that for 10 years and
then going in and playing superman yeah
and maybe there's a thing you know maybe
who knows i always say you know no one's
ever asked me to play lex maybe i'm not
old enough to play lex although jesse
eisenberg is not that old either but
maybe maybe i'll be a better lex when
i'm like in my 50s well there's also
this thing that they're doing that they
started doing in television these
multiverse things which now the films
are embracing and so you could have five
different guys playing superman in the
same movie um you know i think the
batman movie's coming out there's like
uh yeah there's a couple of there's
people coming back from the old films
and whatnot i think the film
television always once filmed people
involved i think film is
slowly allowing television people in
there's still uh
even though viewership i don't think
cares because they don't care if you're
in a movie or on television they're
watching on their ipads anyway you know
what i mean like they don't care but um
i think that there's
you know i think it'd be cool last
question trivia question
how many times
how many times has ryan watched the
smallville series
that reaction i think you're pr trying
to pretend like you haven't watched it
i'm not pretending
you've never seen it i've never seen it
now he's never seen one episode not one
i haven't seen a frame that's probably
good
yeah start it
you know what i'm not saying oh you're
not saying that i'm not saying it's
probably good you haven't seen it it's
probably good that these these stories
then you're like oh what are they
talking about i mean that's
it's all new to me yeah we did that on
smallville well i didn't know who
marshall manhunter was i don't know a
lot of people were people were educating
me they're like this is so-and-so i
didn't know what the [ __ ] was going on
yeah in general um it's better when you
don't know it's better when you don't
know things you're gonna learn about it
when you watch the show uh
shout out to your friend uh amanda's
friend
oh yeah dave dave dave lewis dave lewis
big shout out to you tom sajello to dave
lewis hey dave dave's watched the i know
you're listening six or seven times i
know you're listening i just want to
give a shout out to dave lewis i thought
it'd be funny it's just an inside anyway
dude thank you for allowing me inside of
you i i loved it i mean this it's so
easy just to talk to you this is we're
all the only difference between this
and like any other time is we're just
recording it we're just recording this
is what we do anyway and we don't swear
as much
that's [ __ ] true geez f bomb galore i
love you dude this is awesome and you
haven't farted once uh if i had to i
would have
nope nothing there thanks guys
you know we never know what we're going
to talk about when we start talking and
we just we we talk and hopefully people
give a [ __ ]
that's what you hope you hope that uh
people continue to tune in
a lot of times we have new guests but
sometimes we have guests that you know i
just like having on like kristin krugs
coming back brandon ralph uh you know
tom welling jensen ackles jared
padalecki uh stephen amell there's
certain people zach levi that i have on
more than once that i even like to have
on once a year who's your favorite you
think this year right recurring or just
uh favorite i think in general
oh boy
yeah i remember um like billy magnetson
i think i did like billy magnuson i
think you also liked uh nick frost i
like nick frost uh aussie test five was
a good one ozzy tus5 was a really good
one um
jesus ernie hudson was this here ernie
hudson was really good was you believe
that
wow yeah that was seems like an eternity
ago i know
oh ernie
thank you for coming on thank you to all
my guests for coming on and thank you
again for listening to this podcast uh
there's so many choices you have and uh
the fact that you choose mine the fact
that my patrons are giving to the
podcast and keeping it going is
remarkable so thank you cumulus thank
you ryan my man right here give me a
thumbs up thumbs up baby thumbs up uh
thank you bryce my producer thank you
jason jason my man my main man thank you
man for editing the shows
and again
have a happy holidays uh want to give a
shout out to some organizations
foodonfoot.org helping the homelessness
uh you know if you want to donate
foodonfoot.org i'm sorry foodonfoot.org
yeah for the homeless homelessness
that's going on in los angeles we have
echoes of hope for foster youth
foster youth is
i've got to take care of them um
echoesofhope.org and also the ronald
mcdonald house
um and also if you want to go to the
inside of you online store there's a lot
of great stuff there uh use rosie
christmas10 roscy ten for ten percent
off
and um
have yourselves a merry christmas a
happy holidays
um before i end the show we're gonna do
the top tier of course
but uh
another shout out to those patrons if
you want to join patreon it's patreon
patreon.com inside of you
and uh there's there's tears and there's
uh you know i give gift baskets it's
just a bunch of [ __ ] so check it out
it's become a great family and i love
those guys and let's just go right at it
top tiers
here they are thank you so much for
contributing this year and every year
some of you have been around since the
beginning and supporting this podcast
which is unbelievable ryan wow it is
amazing people stick around because
there's so much you know the attention
span thank god my the majority of my
audience is is is not
18 to 25
because they just [ __ ] split
attention span of fruit flies well
you're just not playing minecraft at the
same time that's your problem yeah
exactly if this podcast was 30 seconds
long they might listen but that's not
what people do but you guys do you
listen and you you hopefully get
something from it here we go nancy d
leah s sarah v little lisa yukiko jill e
bryan h nico p jerry w robert b jason w
kristen k amelia o allison l raj she
joshua d emily s cjp samantha m jennifer
n stacy l gen s jamal f janelle b
kimberly e mike e l don sopremo 99 more
ramirez santiago m chad w leanne p
janine r maya p maddie s belinda and
chris h dave h spider-man
chase sheila g brad d ray h tabitha t mr
m hi mr m liliana a michelle k michelle
s
michael s
uh something my eye here
uh talia m betsy d laura l chat l
rochelle nathan e marion meg k janelle p
trav l dan and big stevie w angel m
rhiannon c corey k super sam coleman g
dev
nixon michelle a liz i jeremy c and dt
cody r sebastian k gav
and nato gavinator david c john b brandy
d yvore camille asked the c
joey m
willie f christina e adelaide n omari
lena l
lena n eugene and lee
uh
eugene and leah would you say leah ellie
ah i always [ __ ] that up yeah that's
alia that's aaliyah eugene and leo hi
eugene lilia i know you guys i just
messed up leah's name chris p nikki g
cory patricia heather l
and jake b
you guys really helped the podcast in so
many ways all my patrons help and uh i
really appreciate you so thank you for
listening to the show all year thank you
for making this
this show uh a priority
ryan i hope you've enjoyed it
i have
sorry i bumped the mic you're all right
there bud i'm good yeah right it's good
ryan's good are you doing anything for
the holidays you're going away going
away going to going to hawaii that's
right go to hawaii for a wedding and
seeing some amanda's family yep that'll
be great we'll have a great time man be
safe i will come back a uh a new man and
a different person he'll come back a
different person hopefully he'll come
back
uh
uh thank you all for allowing me to get
inside of you this year and uh we got
another great podcast coming up next
week so don't miss out uh i think you're
gonna really enjoy it and um
from myself michael rosenbaum here in
the hollywood hills of california no
hollywood hills and ryan tails
a little wave up there to the camera and
uh be good to yourselves all right be
good to yourselves and we'll see you
[Music]